a TPM a TPM da mulher quando ela tá
solteira é totalmente diferente quando
ela tá namorando que quando ela tá
solteira ela tem um mundo inteiro para
descontar essa TPM então o que que
acontece dá para distribuir um pouquinho
cada uma quando ela tá namorando não
quando ela tá namorando ela tem um ser
ó ó
Preto para aguentar TPM Já tá solteira
ela tá conhecendo o cara ela é prima
essa TPM e o homem também não ajuda o
homem é bicho burro homem é bicho burro
para ficar perguntando as coisas que aí
tem o que foi foi alguma coisa mas a
mulher se contém porque ela sabe que
você não é obrigado receber aquela TPM
de uma vez tu tá bem tá todo também tem
certeza tô eu tô bem eu tô achando é
assim eu quero que tu tem nada nada nada
é cansaço é só cansar mesmo que seja
pouco ela consegue controlar como eu
falei antes se ela tivesse solteiro Ela
tem raiva de tudo agora se ela tiver
namorando tem raiva em você ai hoje eu
tô com tanto ódio ódio ódio de quê tá a
vida do mundo das coisas ai namorando Ai
eu tô com tanto ódio ódio de quê De
qualquer